hello
my name is maureen baer and i'm going to
do a very short introduction
to set the stage so you understand the
real world problem that we've been
working on
then ben kicker is going to take you
through all the wolfram work
i'm going to keep my presentation part
very short
so that ben has plenty of time to show
you cool code
we've been looking at metrics and
counting around the united nations
sustainable development goals
for five years and we've been using
wolfram and doing wolfram presentations
at the last five conferences including
this one
talking about the sustainable
development goals and what counting is
for them
for the sdgs the sustainable development
goals
uh the year 2020 is the five-year point
in a 15-year strategic plan for the
world
though the actual results weren't on
target
they were lagging their targets by
around three years or so
by the four year point the beginning of
2020
there was good data collection it was
getting somewhat standardized
and there were plenty of statistics and
reports being produced
at last year's wolfram conference ben
showed you
some of the ways we were combining
wolfram entities with un data
and bringing them together to to look at
maps and geo and other things like that
then covet happened in real world
results
of what the estimates are for what
covett has done to the sustainable
development goals
which are the reflection of what's
happening in the world
in terms of ending poverty the gates
foundation has estimated that the world
will be set
back by 10 or more years
because of the effects of the pandemic
that would be poverty
health care food security education
pretty much anything that you can think
of that makes the world a better place
from a data and statistics point of view
most country statistical offices are
closed
data collection has slowed almost to a
stop
there had always been a lead lag of
about a year in terms of
collecting data and being able to
understand trends
at this point we're expecting that it's
probably going to be
two years at best before the formal data
will be able to be collected again
so we decided um pretty early on in
april
that we would start finding out as much
as we could about where the new
information was happening both around
covid
and looking at what was happening in
terms of larger metrics for the world
things like what was happening to
poverty what was happening
to resources for health etc
and we knew that we wanted to find
ideally computational
information although there was no
formal you know excel spreadsheet
information
available so what we started to do
after we did some you know initial using
google search to see what terms people
were doing
uh ben and i decided that we would start
using wolfram
to find information to structure
information
and analyze it coming in and so now i'm
going to turn it over to ben for the
rest of the presentation
and he'll tell you more about how we've
been using wolfram
thank you maureen i i appreciate it um
so as maureen said
we're looking at ways that we can
look at data that isn't going to be in a
database
we just finished a presentation so
excuse me if my voice is a little bit
um hoarse but we were just looking at um
how we can use
images to create vr learning rooms and
so when you're dealing with
the structure of visual information
coming in um it's not nearly as
easy to work with as what you would find
with um
you know a database or a json query or
things like that so
um we're looking at two things we're
looking at unstructured data
particularly narrative as maureen said
being able to get new information um
coming in that we
couldn't previously but also visual
information how can we share the story
how can we see what information is there
how can we go beyond just a google image
search and actually make things better
so this presentation will be a bit more
of a shotgun style approach
where we'll look at three or four
different things that we've done and
ways that we have engaged
so we'll start very simple looking at
google image search
we'll start adding some machine learning
some simple machine learning to that so
that we can improve our results and the
information that we're pulling in
then we'll start looking at twitter and
how we can actually
take twitter and not just be about
finding people or seeing how many
followers you have
but actually use it as a way to get a
snapshot of what people are talking
about and what is being deemed to be
most important finally we'll take a look
at web session
um so that we can look particularly at
narrative data
on how we can bring that in and analyze
it i didn't mention we
just finished a vr session there's not
really any crossover between the two but
the two definitely do build on them so
you can see a quick screenshot of a vr
room that we've created using some sdg
data
and you can actually click the link
above and go to the
presentation from previously so
we're going to start with web image
search very straightforward function um
you put in a query what do you want to
know
and it'll give you as many images as you
ask for um
but it's when you actually start
combining things and changing your
heuristics
um that this becomes much more useful
and so uh to quickly share just a few of
the things that we found
to be useful to you can leverage this
simple uh function into something a bit
more robust
one of the things is is just simply
looking for bing and google
results and we'll show you a bit about
how those results change
making sure that we're including boolean
operators either within
the wolfram function um or within the
search query that we're using
um we found that combining searches both
in terms of
doing multiple searches that get
combined but also multiple search terms
is always going to give a good result a
quick tip that we found out the hard way
is particularly with your longer strings
wrapping that
in search query string even if you're
not using any boolean or other operators
generally provides results even if you
were getting empty sets to start with
my recommendation is that if you're
working with a lot of large files
that you go ahead and include image
resize as you bring them in
because those files are stored locally
so i think that this notebook
is is about 60 megabytes and most of
what we're looking at is thumbnail so
doing your resize at the beginning can
certainly help with that
um and then also i'd say be willing to
utilize the original apis
um most of these service connects and
and web functions um
are operating on an api in the
background we've done a little bit of
work and particularly with things like
being in article search
um there are ways that you can search in
those apis
that you simply can't within wolfram um
you can use wolfram to do the search but
tie directly into the api um so just a
couple quick
examples simple web image search for the
sustainable development goals which
martin was talking about we asked for
five
and you can see they're almost exactly
the same not particularly useful
to get five different iterations of the
logos
let's add a little bit of detail to that
and ask for sdg results
chart um and we're going to look in both
google and bing and so we see that we we
do have
two that appear to overlap um it's good
to know that
but that means that we're getting other
um inputs or other
data points that are considered high
quality by by different search engines
um so just doing those two searches and
combining them
um is going to give us different results
that are useful
um an example of searching for two terms
we we weren't interested in getting a
lot of the same logo
and diagrams but if we say or the same
logos
and outlines of the sdgs but if we say
sdg diagram
now we're getting a lot of new and
different information um
we can also combine multiple searches
which we talked about so we're
interested right now in kovan 19
renewable energy virtual reality impact
investing in wolfram
mathematica and so we can pull in two of
each of those
if you were in the vr talk previously
this is a little bit more fleshed out
version of how we were creating the data
points for those
those vr for those vr rooms um
here we're actually using tuples to be
able to pull in multiple aspects of the
same
search term and so three of the sdgs
that we focus a lot on are sdg3 which is
health
sdg 5 which is gender equality and sdg 7
which is affordable and clean energy and
so we wanted to pull in both the logo
as well as the infographic again this
has a use for the vr rooms but but
that's not the only thing
we can pull in multiple aspects of a of
a single
of a single search term um but now when
you pull it in especially as you start
dealing with
larger sets of images you find that you
end up with a lot of stuff that just
isn't that good you know we might get a
nice picture of a
local farmer in rural america
but that doesn't help us when we want to
know about data
and so using very basic ai
machine learning functions we've tried
to look at ways that we can improve the
information that's that's coming out
um so that whether we're creating pdfs
whether we're creating archives of the
information that's that's coming out
that we can
sort and and simplify the process of
finding the best material
um so here again very straightforward
web image search we're asking for covid
trends i'm just looking at the the first
10 and all 10 of these look to be
you know probably pretty helpful for us
and we can utilize them
but we also know that within this set
we've got some advertisements and we've
got some
logos we've got some report covers that
aren't particularly
useful if we're wanting to actually
digest and be able to look at this
information
so using the feature nearest function we
can take
all of those images that we've just
pulled in
and and run the function and create
create this set to go off of
and then using that what i've done is as
i've looked through my set and i've said
that that picture right there
um that one looks to be um very useful
for me i i like this picture here it's
um you know you've got comparisons
between countries so let's try to get
some more pictures
like that um so i i run the function and
i say
give me all of the results and so what
this does is is
we're only working with 50 but if you
were to have 500 of varying qualities
everything from
you know pictures of people's dogs to
charts to
um you know logos and and advertisements
um you want to be able to put them in a
way that's most useful so all we're
doing here is we're saying
this chart i like that one um that one
works well for me
so line them up most to least similar to
that chart
and so as you can see as you go down all
of these we're dealing with a lot of
multi-line charts
um we start getting into some bar charts
which might not be what i want we've got
an infographic
we start changing some some colors we
start getting into some of the geo
mapping which
may be helpful to us but isn't similar
to what i've said and we go all the way
down to our
insurance industry trends that you
should know and a lady with an umbrella
um so rather than having to to flip
through pages
um of of options this allows you to sort
mostly similar in images and say you
know what we're gonna we're gonna take
all of those out
delete those and it's gonna be our new
data set
if you're dealing with more diverse sets
where there's multiple types of images
that would be useful
you can use the find clusters function
in this case we end up with a very large
cluster
of charts similar to what we want as we
get down to the bottom
you start seeing that a lot of these you
know you've got your maps here which may
or may not be useful to you
and you can start pulling in and out of
clusters so using a single function
on your image sets it allows you to
process through what's what's happening
so if you're interested in what's
happening in open 19 and trends
this is a great way to start if you're
starting uh you you're you know starting
a
vacation planning um you can you know
pull up
related images um along that away as
well
so that's images that's the that's the
very straightforward
uh visual approach to what we're doing
um next i want us to take a look at
twitter
um and if if you've been to any of our
talks at previous sessions twitter's
something we've used quite a bit in a
lot of different ways
we've used it to you know track our
effectiveness and engagement we've used
it
as ways to find new followers and people
that we should be listening to
but here we want to use twitter as a way
of getting a very timely snapshot
of what people are talking about around
a topic
so using the twitter service connect and
and putting in a tweet search for the
query sdg data
we can pull in all the details that we
need about
sdg data and the tweets that come in
so if if you're a if you're wanting to
structure something as unstructured as
twitter
um this does it this does it for you
with a single function
but we start to see that we've got some
issues so for instance here we see
that this is the exact same tweet it's
just been retweeted
but we're not getting any new
information
i can't really scroll in presentation
mode but if you go over to the far right
you'll see that a lot of these tweets
have no engagement um and so
they might be relevant to what we're
talking about um but they're they're not
getting the traction people aren't
really engaging with those and so they
might not be the best um indicator of
what people
are resonating with um but what we can
do just by bringing that in is we can
um we can get a visual snapshot um on a
topic that we're interested in
so within sdg data what are people
talking about
um the general populace here we see a
lot of discussion about
currency and money and values and
transactions
and i know because i looked it up that
there's actually a conference going on
now that's looking at
gender equality and wage gap and so a
lot of people who are talking about sdg
data today are talking about what's
happening at that conference
if we look at who's being mentioned and
who's being talked about um
you know we we see the u.n data forum
and so if i had forgotten that it's
coming up in two weeks
i can be reminded that oh yeah that's
that's something important coming up so
let's pay attention to it
um we see the mo ibram foundation is
being mentioned a lot
they are well known for putting out
reports on african governance and
leadership
um and so most likely we can infer that
something new has come up from them that
maybe we should pay attention to
um so those are those are kind of the
straightforward searches
um but what we found is that um doing
searching whether it's through web image
search
whether it's through regular web search
wiki data data
um that a lot has to do with how you're
structuring your query
and it's much more art than science um a
lot of
iterations to get to places where we can
say this is giving us the picture that
we want
when we're talking about twitter one of
the things we found to be most useful
is actually working within twitter's
query system
and doing a lot of filtering before you
even get to
uh the the tweets coming into
mathematica
and so i've given you three options here
the twitter advanced search
is kind of a gui that you can interact
with and when you click search it'll
give you the query up
top that you can then import into into
your your twitter search as a query
um the actual developer documentation
will give you some operators that you
can use
um and then just an independent website
that lists quite a few hidden
search operators that can make for a
more powerful search experience
so in this case we before we just search
for sdg and data
now we're going to start working with
some of our boolean commands and we're
going to say you know there's a lot of
terms that can be related to
um to the sdgs and so we want
sdgs we want global goals we want global
goals together we want sustainable
development
um hlpf is the high level political
forum and the human data form are two
events that
talk exclusively about what we're
interested in so find any tweet
that talk about that and that are
mentioning data
and stats and targets and reports um and
then to make sure we're getting the best
data possible um we want uh we want
language being english i i'm embarrassed
to say that
is my only language of competency we
want to filter out any of the
native retweets um so that we don't get
duplicates as people are retweeting the
same information
as a way of vetting our results we only
want tweets that have been retweeted at
least twice or favorited at least twice
um and so that we found in some of our
earlier studies we would end up with
some very off-the-wall tweets
um that had nothing to do with with this
you know buy bitcoin
elon musk and tesla wants to give you a
thousand dollars all that stuff
this allows us to bypass that um once it
comes in we go ahead and do a reverse
sort
by the amount of engagement and so here
we now have a
more simplified and straightforward
understanding of what people are
talking about and on topic that we've
decided
again if you look at a word cloud just
for a quick visual understanding
you see that this is much more focused
we have global goals and sdgs
that's what we're interested in we might
not be getting the you know the broad
look at what's happening
but we know that what's coming in is
related to what we're interested in
um to add and again tying into what we
can either do with a vr learning room
or um what you can do with other sorts
of reports
is we actually want to focus a little
bit more on images and so
one of the filters that we've recently
started using is that you can filter and
only bring in
tweets that have images associated with
them so if you're interested in a
conference the wolfram technology
conference for
instance you can do a wtc search
that only returns images so if seth
handler has a picture of a screenshot
from last night at the
keynote you can you can bring that in
so here we're gonna do the initial
search we are going to
tweak um our service connect command
by simply adding elements and images so
for all of those in
those tweets that we found only bring in
the the images and so it's a
straightforward way of doing it
this next section i'm going to run
through because it's pretty specific to
our work and the way that we do things
but sometimes you you want to visualize
a tweet data sets are great
if you want to have structured
information and be able to search
but sometimes simply seeing it is a
better way to work
and so what we've done is we actually
want to look at ways to take a quick
snapshot
of what those tweets are you can use
the web image function which is very
straightforward
it essentially opens up the website
takes a snapshot of what's there and
sends it back to you
um unfortunately when we we started
implementing this particularly with
twitter
we found that there's some errors with
it so here you can see the tweet was not
fully loaded
and so it's partially grayed out and in
fact about half of our
tweets um hadn't even showed up by the
time that they were there
um but luckily you you can use a web
session
um and you can recreate that exact same
um the exact same process
and add your own your own steps to it so
in this case
we've created a defined function where
we're going to open up the url that
we're interested in
we are going to set the window size and
so this took some trial and error but we
can find out what's the optimal size so
that we're not truncating our
our tweets but we're also not ending up
with too much information on the left
right
um so then we can pause for one second
to ensure
that the website has time to load and
then finally take a capture page
um command with web execute to to return
that image
um and so for here here's an example of
10 of the tweets
i'll show you what this would look like
if we use in the vr room but if you're
more of a visual
learner um you might you know you're
jumping on a plane and you want to
you know have you know give me the 500
most uh interesting tweets on my topic
uh download all the images um and you
can read them while you're
while you're on the plane um we're gonna
crop the images make them work a little
bit better
um and what we have here is that the vr
hallway
um and i can actually bring that bring
that up for you as
a tie into our previous work so again if
you were a visual learner
this would work on a vr headset so
instead of being on your phone on
twitter
um you can you can walk through a
hallway and and look at the tweet so if
uh the placement of things resonates
with you and helps you remember it
um you have that as a as an option um
obviously you can also export that as a
pdf which which we discussed
um and we've gotten a little bit more
into automating our reports coming out
of this
um so for instance we will take a search
that we we know is effective
and we'll set it as a cloud deployed
scheduled task and so
every day i think this comes in for me
like nine o'clock in the morning
um the wolfram cloud is going to run a
tweet search
and then it's gonna send me the data set
um so that i can include it we've also
worked with data bins so that you can
collect information over time you can
track trends
we've used this to create a twitter
retweet bot
so if you go to sdg counting at twitter
right now you'll see that we have a lot
of activity but because we've been busy
preparing for these presentations we
haven't been doing it um the the
original tweeting and so
everything that's coming out is the um
is the result of our our twitter retweet
bot
um we've mentioned daily summary reports
um and we're also looking at ways that
you can auto generate
articles in a new source like medium
which is a
cross between a blog and twitter for
quick information
sharing now we've already touched on
a little bit about how web session can
be used
here we want to take that idea of what
is narrative and how can we move
narrative into a more structured
approach
so again using medium as a a lot of
citizen journalism happens on medium
we can open up a web session in chrome
we can open up
the website for the search for coke 19
data statistics
um to see what the most recent articles
related to code 19 data statistics are
um using web execute with our web
session um
and identifying our css selectors we can
have wolfram go in
and find all of the titles um take a
quick look and we can say yeah those uh
we're interested in stats and kobu
that that looks good to me one more bit
of code that i want to give a
give credit to uh from swish on stack
exchange
um this is probably one of the most
useful web session add-ins that i've
come across
um it allows you to extract additional
information from a web object
that you've identified and so for
instance if you if you've identified
an image or a link within an image or
you've identified the image
and you want to find out what is the
href within that this allows you to set
that
attribute so for us we know that
we have a division that points to an a
tag
and we want to extract the href argument
that's within there and so what that
does is it allows us to get all of the
um all of the links for the the 10
articles that we've identified
previously now i won't go through the
specifics
but i will mention a few things in terms
of our overall import process
one of the things we ran into with
medium is that it doesn't auto load the
page
uh you have to scroll down and then
it'll load and scroll down some more and
it will load
and so we've included some code in our
defined function
that will automatically scroll down so
that we can ensure that the entire pages
has load as loaded um then we can bring
in our title do some pre-processing on
date
pull in the full text um the headings
subheadings what people are putting in
the bold what tags were used
what internal links are in the article
um what the embedded files are
and then do some cleaning up at the end
and so here we have now taken
what is citizen journalism in a very
unstructured um
and narrative way and now we have
a whole data set that we need to do
analytics on or we can use it to store
again to look at trends um take a look
at the tags that are people being used
um but if if you are a visual uh learner
and more of a
summary type person um one of the things
that we've done
is to take the essential information so
if you have a new article
that you don't know how interested
you're going to be in it
you're going to look at the title you're
going to look at the headings you're
going to look at what the block quotes
are
and you're going to look at what people
are putting into bold
and so this then gives a quick snapshot
of every page coming in
maureen's talked about national
statistics offices already um
and so just by glancing at this rather
than having to go through each
individual website
you get that snapshot and so i know that
that's probably an article
that i'm going to want to to read again
all of this can be automated you can
have a report of the most
recent and useful information delivered
straight to your email or
put into into another
source um so my conclusion i i think
we've covered most of what we've talked
about i think that
um when you're looking at unstructured
data um
oftentimes it involves a lot of um
trial and error and a lot of figuring
out how things can be structured so that
they're useful
it often requires a different way of
learning i i do like
um you know my my tables and my rows and
my columns
um but sometimes having more of the
quick snapshot
is a is a better way of doing that um in
terms of our next steps
things that we're wanting to do with
this um this was brought about because
of covid
um that that certainly affected the way
that we've had to
um we've had to learn uh but it's
something that will be useful into our
topics
as we continue um so the next thing we
want to do is to explore more automation
uh with the machine learning uh so you
saw that it's still a very hands-on
process
to decide what images were most relevant
um we want to make that a little bit
more automated
we want to include text recognize text
recognized functionality
on some of the image output so that we
can include other data points
continue to expand on the use of ai
functionality what we shared today
was relatively straightforward we want
to expand that into some of the neural
nets that are available through the
repository
um and finally this is kind of our gold
standard that we're wanting to
achieve is to be able to take a lot of
these un um pdf reports
um be able to extract the uh
the relevant graphics as well as the
information that is in there
so that is the conclusion of my
presentation um
i have looks like two minutes i will
stick around um after this ends to
answer any of the questions that uh
um that comes up on the chat
um i'm not sure i'm gonna do a good job
of reading through them and trying to
answer on the fly so let me end it there
um thank you maureen
for the introduction and for the drive
to get a lot of this uh work completed
uh we appreciate you you coming and
attending uh the session
we will upload our notebook for you to
use and dig through
um into our pathway account so feel free
to find it there
um and reach out to us with any
questions that you may have or anything
that we can
assist with or vice versa things that uh
you might be able to help us with we
would appreciate that um so thank you
all for your time
and uh have a great afternoon and there
are a couple of questions that came in
through pathable
um and we'll be sure to get back to you
chase particularly i think you had a
couple of questions
um and for me also thanks everybody for
attending appreciate it